SANDEEP PARIKH: Today I want
to talk about the hybrid data
lifecycle.
And I'll get into
what that really
means, because the title
is a little bit misleading.
My name is Sandeep Parikh.
I run the Google Cloud
solutions architecture team
for Americas East.
What I want you to think about
and take away from this session
is really
understanding that data
lives in multiple environments.
It's not just on premise,
it's not just in cloud.
It's kind of in both places.
And even in on
premise scenarios,
you might have a sort
of core infrastructure,
you might have
private cloud, you
might have other
virtualised infrastructure.
The idea is that data
is kind of spread out
in a bunch of places.
And what I want to
do is kind of take
that thought
process, particularly
from the on premise
perspective, and map that
to what we think of
as the data lifecycle
through four applied scenarios,
or practical scenarios.
As I said earlier
when we opened,
it's kind of a hybrid world.
Whatever you want to call
it-- hybrid, heterogeneous,
multi cloud--
you've got applications and
infrastructure kind of spread
out across a number of
different environments.
How many of you have a
scenario similar to this
that you're running into
at your own organizations?
You've got multiple
environments.
You've got data spread
out across different ones.
Each one is sort of satisfying
different workloads.
The problem is it's hard to
wrap your hands around all
these things in one place.
So how do you tackle
those problems
as it relates to things
like processing big data,
or handling large
scale ingests coming in
from applications
or from devices?
That's the sort of stuff we want
to try to unpack and figure out
as best as possible.
Why do you even consider
going down this hybrid route?
Why would you even look at this?
Everything is great on premise.
We should just
stay there forever.
Let's never leave.
But the reality
is that there are
a lot of challenges when you're
in an on-prem environment.
You've got things like
maxed out resources.
That means if you want to
deploy new applications,
if you want to deploy new
features or functionality,
you've got to pull
those resources back
from something else, and
perhaps pay a latency
or a throughput penalty.
That's not a great option.
You might just have generic
sort of compute limitations.
People might have
to wait in line
to run big processing
jobs and whatnot.
And ultimately, what
that sort of adds up to
is sort of the third
item, which is, the time
it takes to kind of
get meaningful insight
and understanding
out of your data
and deliver that back,
not only to the business
but to your end
customer, is pretty long.
You're trying to get
out of this cycle
where you're bumping up
against the ceiling of what
you have access to.
And you want to be able to get
information and understanding
back out to every part
of the organization
and, again, to your customers,
as quickly as possible.
So what are the
approaches you could take?
So the one that people always
think we're going to tell them
is, just pick up everything,
put it in a truck,
and drive it over to GCP.
And while that's perfectly
fine if you really
want to go down that road, it's
not without its challenges.
And I could trivialize
a bunch of the details,
but the reality is that that
approach is really hard.
If you try to pick all that
stuff up today and move it
to the cloud, you're going
to have trouble, right?
People are going to be unhappy.
Things are going to break.
Ultimately what
might happen is, you
might drop data on the floor.
You might build one off
migration processes that aren't
going to scale over time.
You're going to run into
a lot of rough edges.
And frankly, you're just
not going to be happy.
So instead of trying to say
let's move everything over,
go whole hog right off the
gate, instead let's find ways
to sort of bridge the gap.
Let's move certain
workloads that make sense.
Let's try to find
an easy on ramp
and let the cloud be
your place for scale,
new applications,
compelling functionality
that you couldn't do
because you're maxed out
in on premise scenarios.
So what is the data lifecycle?
At least, what do we think
of the data lifecycle as?
Well, it's basically
four main steps.
You've got ingest, and
that's data coming out
of applications, data
coming out of devices,
mobile applications,
what have you.
But that data is coming
into your infrastructure
in some meaningful way.
So the first thing
you're going to do
is, you're going to
capture all that stuff
and you're going to
store it somewhere.
You might store that in
a variety of databases.
It could be anything to
like objects, log files,
into something like an object
storage infrastructure.
It could be relational data.
It could be semi-structured
and go into either key value,
document, wide column
database infrastructure.
And then you've got to do
something with that data.
You want to actually
churn through it
all in some meaningful
way and start
extracting a little
bit of value out of it.
So you want to go
through that step
of processing all the
data, joining things
together, de-normalizing
things in some cases,
and then analyzing it.
And then you get
to the last step,
where you get to really explore
and visualize that data.
And that's where
you start generating
that really deep intelligence
about what your organization is
really doing.
So if you take those four steps
and you map them on to four
what I call, kind of
practical scenarios
that we talk about a
lot with customers,
what does that look like?
So the first scenario
is kind of basic.
You've got on prime
relational infrastructure.
But you need to adopt a
data warehouse approach.
You need something that's going
to let you scale out a lot,
and that might not
just be one database,
and frankly it probably
isn't just one database.
It's probably a dozen or so
disparate, distinct sources
of data, distinct data types.
But you've got to put
all that stuff together
in order to get an
understanding of your business
from a number of
different angles.
So one is, again, moving on-prem
relational to a data warehouse.
And that's kind of
under the Process phase
and under the Explore phase
of the data lifecycle.
The next one is migrating
Hadoop and Spark workloads
to the cloud.
This is usually easy,
low hanging fruit
for a lot of people,
because they can just
pick up their jobs and
move them somewhere else.
But we're trivializing
a pretty critical detail
which is, those big data
deployments on premise
usually have a lot of data.
And it's not like
you can turn off
the sources of data one day,
move everything, and turn it
back on.
That data is coming into the
system on a regular basis.
So you have to find a way
to move everything once,
in one fell swoop, and get that
ongoing, incremental transfer
to make sense.
And that falls into the
Process and Analyze phase
of the lifecycle.
The other one I
want to talk about
is cloud applications
plus on-prem data.
Listen, I'll be
honest with you, not
every data source, not
every application, frankly,
is a good fit for cloud.
There is a lot of
stuff that might
have to stay on prem,
for a variety of reasons.
It could be compliance.
It could be in-depth security
concerns you might have.
It could be other
business requirements
that we might not
even know about.
But the idea is that
there are some things that
have to stay there.
So, how do I enable development
teams to deliver new features
and functionality to a wide
variety of customers, but still
having access to that
data that sits on prem?
How do I front that for them
so they can go build something
compelling while still not
really upsetting the balance
of what's here on premise?
So that's kind of in
the Ingest and Store
phase of the lifecycle.
And the last one is
kind of the same thing.
Inset at the Ingest and
Store phase, but think back
to those on-prem
challenges, where
you're maxed out on resources.
What if you have an insanely
great IoT idea tomorrow?
You've got this compelling--
hilariously compelling
connected light bulb, and you
want to get these things out.
You're talking about millions
and millions of households
with 10, 20, 30 bulbs in there.
That's a lot of data.
That's a lot of events
being generated.
That's a lot of on
and off switches
that are controlling
these things, that
are pushing data through.
You might not have
enough infrastructure--
you might not have enough
infrastructure to actually take
all that data in.
So where is it going to go?
You've got to put
that stuff somewhere.
But you've also got to
remember to enable the business
to learn from that.
There might be internal
applications, again,
living on prem, that
need access to this data.
So how do you facilitate that
circuitous lifecycle there
around where the
data is going to go
and how you get access to it?
So those are the
four workloads I
want to talk about a
little bit in-depth,
and how you tackle
each one of them.
The important thing to remember
is that in all these scenarios,
you've got to be heterogeneous,
hybrid, multi cloud, whatever.
You've got to be friendly to
this concept, which means--
and again, I'm not going to
go through all this right now
in this talk, but definitely
come find me afterwards.
There are a lot of concerns
that are at the foundation level
there.
How do you handle security?
How do you handle
governance, ownership?
Who has identity and access
control to all these things?
Those are all really important
things to think about.
And it's critical that you
work through those open items
before you go down this road.
Because once you do
that, then you've
opened the door to
scaling on both sides.
But again, you've got
to take on this sort
of heterogeneous lifestyle
approach to the world.
And then frankly, you've got
to have this thing be scalable,
because otherwise
what's the point?
If you can't scale it
on a cloud environment
or in a public cloud,
then this approach
really isn't going to work
in any of these cases.
So let's dig into each one
of those practical scenarios
and walk through what
they look like tactically.
So the first one is
on-prem relational
to cloud data warehouse.
So it's really simple.
Just do this.
And that's it, the talk is done.
No, I'm kidding.
The idea is, you've got to get
database-- and frankly, again,
databases, but I didn't want
to fill up too many icons
on the slide, but--
you've got multiple databases.
You want to get them to
something like BigQuery,
because you want to be
able to do ad hoc SQL.
You want to explore that data.
You want to look at it
normalized, de-normalized.
You want to cut it
up and slice it up.
You want to build compelling
reporting and dashboards
on top of all of your
disparate data sources.
Well, how do you go from
on-prem to cloud in that case?
So the first thing
that we're going to do
is, we're going to put
Apache Beam in here.
And I'll talk a little bit
about why Beam is a good choice.
So, Beam is a very modern
approach to data processing.
It's very pipeline centric.
So as data comes into it
the pipeline you create,
you can apply a series
of operations to it.
And at any point
in that pipeline,
you can break out and dump
things wherever you want to.
But the idea is, you
can have a pipeline that
starts with multiple
data sources,
and funnel them
through, and again, do
things like in-flight
aggregation,
if there's time
fields in there you
can start windowing
some of that data.
Basically, you can ETL that data
into whatever format it takes.
But what's really
interesting about Apache Beam
is that it unifies the model
between batch processing
and stream processing.
So, for example, today the
problem you might be solving
is, I've got a
bunch of databases
and I want to ETL them into some
kind of cohesive data warehouse
structure.
And that might be a batch job.
But tomorrow, you might
say, I'm moving that to--
I'm going to start including
streaming data sources.
The great thing about Beam
is that there's pretty much
no change to your code.
You effectively have to
change the inputs to your code
and say this is a streaming
source versus a batch source.
And your code just works
the same way at that point.
There's no real change.
And that's a really powerful
concept to work through.
Beam is also really
compelling because it's
portable across a number
of runtime environments.
If you've already
got a YARN cluster
running MapReduce
or Spark on premise,
Beam can sit right on top of
Spark and run on top of Spark.
Or it can actually run
on top of Link as well.
And then when you want to get
into the cloud environment,
Beam can actually run in
the cloud dataflow service
that Google offers.
And I'll talk a little
bit about that as well.
And right now, as
of today actually,
Beam supports building
pipelines in Java or Python.
So you have that ability
to mix and match depending
on what makes sense for the
skill set that your teams have.
So Apache Beam is
really interesting.
If you go way, way, way back
into the early 2000's, back
when Google only
wrote research papers
and didn't really build
the public facing products
around them, MapReduce is
one of the first papers.
I would say MapReduce and
GFS, Google File System,
were one of the first
two papers that I think
really came out
and helped kick off
a whole host of other
research at Google,
and a bunch of things
that ultimately became
part of the Hadoop ecosystem.
So if you think about,
again, Google File System,
that was basically
what became HDFS.
The MapReduce paper is what
became Hadoop and the follow
on between MapReduce 1.0 and
the YARN approach that came
and Hadoop 2.
But there's a strong
lineage here for Apache Beam
to build on top of.
And in fact, over
the last few years,
Google has actually moved away
from MapReduce internally,
into a number of other tools.
Not just a new distributed
storage approach, but also
a distributed compute
and processing approach,
and the product of all of those
things over the last few years
was something we
called Cloud Dataflow.
Cloud Dataflow came out, I
think maybe 18 months ago.
And it was great.
It's a very powerful tool.
But what we saw was the need
for adopting a more open source
mindset, because we want to
see Dataflow be successful.
We want to see--
but even more than
Dataflow, we want
to see the idea of
batch and stream
processing become successful
from this unified code base.
So what we did is,
we took Dataflow
and we split the two things out.
One is the service
that we run for you,
and the other is the
SDK portion, which
is what became Apache Beam.
So now what you
can do is, you can
write your pipelines in
Apache Beam, fully open source
under Apache, and then run them,
Spark, Flink, or on Dataflow.
So you get a ton of
portability for runtime, which
is a really powerful concept
because again, as you think
about this world where
you started from on-prem
and you're slowly making
your way into the cloud,
you're not going to dump
those original data sources.
They just might be located
in a different place.
They might be running
on GCP, inside
of things like Cloud SQL,
cloud storage, BigTable, Cloud
Datastore, Cloud Spanner even.
But you still want to use
the same Beam pipelines.
So instead of running
them on premise
on top of a Spark
or Flink cluster,
you can actually run those Beam
pipelines inside of Dataflow.
So that's where-- that's some
of the history around that.
Beam is actually,
again, pretty cool.
It has four main
modes of operation.
Very classically,
a big batch job,
the ability to do
windowed batches.
If you want to do it by
time or by data set sizes.
You can also do things
like streaming again out
of the same codebase, or
streaming plus accumulation,
which is a little
bit in the weeds
so we won't spend a
ton of time on it.
So this is an example
of the Beam pipeline.
And on the left I've
got the batch version,
on the right I've got
the streaming version.
And if you look,
I only really had
to change three lines of
code to make this work.
There's a little
bit left out here,
I've glazed over a
handful of details.
But the important
thing is that I
went from a file based input,
which is the batch source,
and a file based output, to a
streaming input and a streaming
output, just by changing
the inputs and outputs.
Nothing else in the
middle there had
to change as far as
the functionality goes.
So when you think about running
Beam pipelines in Dataflow,
what are the advantages?
Why would you even
go down this road?
And it's really
important to understand
that we take the idea
of managed services
and managed infrastructure
very seriously.
We think it's a really critical
component of how Cloud should
work and be built.
And we want to see
people be successful
without having
to sit there and fiddle
with individual VMs
and worry about scale
up and scale down
in a lot of these examples.
So Dataflow lets you
take a Beam pipeline.
You push it to the
Dataflow service.
We scale up that pipeline,
and scale it down for you,
depending on what
the input looks like.
So if you're streaming
data in, and we
see the volume of the
stream start going up,
we'll add more infrastructure.
As we see the volume
in the stream go down,
we'll reduce the infrastructure.
Just like the data
set size if you're
doing batch mode,
if you see that you
have a lot of data coming in--
if you've selected
a data source that's
got a lot of data
set size to it--
we'll go ahead and give
you a much larger cluster.
And you have the ability to
control min and max there,
about how you want to handle
it and how quickly you
need to get the data back.
But the important
thing is that you
don't have to go and
actually provision
and configure those
virtual machines.
We do all that for you.
And then there's
other great things
like a built in UI for
monitoring and understanding
your pipeline and debugging it.
And then we do a bunch of other
stuff on top of that as well.
So, two things that
we've added recently--
or that we've gone more
depth into recently,
are templates and orchestration.
With templates, you
can actually define
a series of inputs
in your code that you
want us to be able to templatize
and parameterize at runtime.
So instead of having to push
your job every single time
you want to run it
with new parameters,
you can stage the
job once, tell us
which parameters
can be adjusted,
and then you can launch
this from either the UI
or from the API just by
passing in the new parameters
every single time.
And I'll just jump
ahead for a second,
but this is what it looks
like to create a template.
You've got to add a
little bit of metadata
into your code around
all the parameters you're
going to supply.
And then we can go ahead and
make it really easy to, again,
run from a staging environment
very, very quickly.
If you take that idea back to
Orchestration, what happens
is you can start coming up
with really compelling ways
to get your pipeline
up and running.
If you've got a templatized
Dataflow job, or a Beam
pipeline that you've saved
in Dataflow, and you want to,
maybe, kick off a job every time
you get a pub/sub notification.
Or you want to kick
off a job every time
a new log file is put
into cloud storage,
or certain rows are added
to a cloud SQL table.
You can do that really easily.
And you can orchestrate
it through things
like App Engine with Cron,
or through Cloud Functions.
And both of those
can actually just
go ahead and kick off a
Dataflow job just for you.
Again, without having to
stage and upload JAR files
and push those things out.
So it's a pretty
compelling way to run.
On the template front, we have
a couple of baked examples
that are in the docs, like
WordCount and Cloud Pub/Sub
to BigQuery.
WordCount is certainly
the Hello World
of Apache Beam or Dataflow.
But actually Cloud
Pub/Sub to BigQuery
is a very common thing.
We see people want to
take streaming pipelines
and go straight to
BigQuery with just
a little bit of transformation.
And so that's an easy one
that you can try out as well.
All right, so that
was the first one,
moving on-prem
relational to cloud.
And again, there's a ton of
detail under the covers there.
So if anybody has
questions on this,
I urge you to hit the mics
or find me after the talk.
I'm happy to walk you through
some of the things I left out.
So the next one is migrating
Hadoop and Spark workloads
to the cloud.
That's a very popular one.
Migrating the Hadoop
and Spark part,
to be totally honest with
you, trivial, super easy.
Right You've already
got JAR files built.
You might have some
supporting libraries
that have to go with them.
But ultimately, you just have
to deploy those jobs on us,
as opposed to pointing them
to your local YARN master.
That's not the hard part.
The hard part is moving data.
You've got gigabytes, petabytes
of data stored in HGFS.
How do you actually, physically,
truck that over to us-- well,
not physically, but
how do you actually
move that data over to
us in a reasonable manner
that again, not just one time--
because one time is easy.
It's one time, plus
the ongoing transfer.
And for that, we have a couple
of great partners in Attunity
and Wandiscco-- who are
downstairs, by the way,
on the first floor.
They would love to talk
to you more about this.
But basically,
they have software
that you run on premise that
lets you facilitate the one
time transfer, and the
ongoing incremental transfer.
And that's really
important because,
if you go back to
what I said earlier--
and this is kind of a
personal philosophy of mine.
I hate telling people to move
everything in one fell swoop.
One fell swoop is not easy.
it's pretty hard, and
it's a lot of pain.
You're better off trying
to find an approach that
lets you slowly
make the transition,
and then lets you
run really fast.
If you try to do everything at
once, things don't work well.
You're much better off trying
to find an approach that
lets you start slow
and keep running
faster and faster and faster.
And then over time, you can
get rid of the on premise HTFS
cluster, once you've
made that transition
and you've migrated data
sources and ingest over
to Cloud as well.
All right, so let's say
we've done this process.
We've got the batch
transfer going.
We got the incremental
What does it look
like when you're
starting to run Cloud Dataproc,
which is our management Hadoop
and Spark service.
Dataproc is kind of cool.
We do a lot of work-- and this
is another core philosophy
of Google Cloud--
we do a lot of work to
separate storage and compute.
We want them to be able
to scale independently.
So instead of having
you run HDFS on GCP,
we tell you to
run Cloud Storage.
Cloud Storage is always
on, always available,
all the nines you
need on availability.
The idea is that you
do all your storage
that you would typically
have done in HDFS, inside
of Cloud Storage.
And you spin up Cloud Dataproc
clusters for Hadoop and SPARC
to actually do the compute
aspect of your job.
Cloud Dataproc lets you
spin up compute jobs--
or compute clusters,
I should say--
in about 90 seconds.
And that's true of clusters
that are anywhere from 10 nodes
to 100 nodes, to 1,000
nodes, to even larger.
And if you start to
think about that,
1,000 nodes with 64 cores each.
That's a lot of CPU
power you can get.
Or if you're thinking of
Spark for a RAM perspective,
that's up to 416 gigs
of RAM per instance
that's running out there.
So it's a pretty big number.
You've got a lot of memory
headroom to work with.
And those clusters actually do
spin up in about 90 seconds.
It's probably on the
order of 70 to 90 seconds,
but we say 90 just
in case there's
a hiccup somewhere
in there to give us
a little bit of head room.
And Cloud Dataproc's got
built in monitoring, logging,
that sort of thing.
And the best part is
that you get to follow
the same open source train.
So if you're familiar with
the Apache Bigtop project,
it's kind of this idea
where they sort of
draw a line in the
sand around all
the versions of the software and
call that a particular release.
And it might be Hadoop 2.x
something, Spark 2.something,
Pig, Hive, et cetera.
That's a Bigtop release.
So we follow the
Bigtop release train,
which is similar to what
Hortonworks does as well.
In practice, Dataproc
is actually kind of cool
as well, because you
can resize clusters
on the fly, including not just
the number of nodes in there,
but things like attach
disks, or if you
want to adjust the
way the networking
layout is on your cluster.
We also have custom VMs.
So if you want to
skew higher on memory
and lower on cores, for example,
like in the case of Spark
workloads, that's
certainly possible.
You just tell us the
shape of the VM you want,
and we'll use that
for the worker pool.
The third point--
and this is what
I think is the most compelling
one about Dataproc--
is the ability to use
preemptable virtual machines.
So just by a show
of hands, who's
heard of preemptables
in the room?
OK, so a fair amount.
So just real quick,
preemptables are super powerful.
This is a machine that we can
give you for up to 24 hours.
After that, we can take
it away at any time.
But the idea is that it
runs at 80% off list price.
There's no limitation
on configuration.
It's the same exact VMs you get
access to, except we can just--
we can preempt it, basically,
within a 24 hour window.
Now, if you think about how
that maps back to your jobs,
instead of running a job that
takes two days on 100 nodes,
why not run that job that takes
less than a day on 200 nodes?
Or 500 nodes?
Or 1000 nodes?
Because you're running with
a dramatically reduced cost,
you can actually dramatically
scale up your cluster size
and get the compute job
done that much faster.
And on top of that, we actually
have permanent billing,
which means every minute you
shave off that runtime means
that much less you're spending.
So it's an important
metric to start
thinking about how to map
your compute jobs around.
And then on top of-- the other
critical part of Dataproc
is the ability to
bootstrap a cluster.
Because we know you're
not just probably going
to run MapReduce or
Spark in a vanilla form.
You're probably going to
want to tweak those things.
So not only in tuning
cluster parameters,
but also the ability to install
things like Kafka, or Jupiter,
or Zookeeper, or any other
kind of open source packages.
We have a bunch of preexisting
bootstrap templates
to do all that stuff.
And then we give you
easy instructions
on how to bootstrap it with
your own custom software.
So if you've got
custom JAR files
you want to spread across the
cluster, or custom applications
that you've built,
you can push those out
pretty easily as well.
The one thing to take away,
that I would urge you all
to take away from this
idea around Cloud Dataproc,
is this transition from being
a cluster centric approach,
to a very job centric approach.
Instead of saying, listen, I
have a 100 node Hadoop cluster
that everybody shares, and we're
all going to try to fit into it
and make sure we can get all our
work done in a reasonable time,
instead you shift your thinking.
You turn it on its
head and you say,
what if every job could
just have its own cluster?
What if every job could run
as fast as they wanted to
and get done super quickly?
What could-- what kind
of impact could that
have on your ability to use
your data in a meaningful way?
So that's the idea
with Cloud Dataproc.
We want people to move
away from this notion
of having to run a single large
stateful cluster all the time,
and instead make them move to
a very job centric approach.
Because now you're letting
everybody scale themselves
individually.
And again, if you start
taking advantage of things
like preemptable VMs,
custom VM sizing,
you're getting the most
optimal deployment,
the most optimal
compute cluster,
for the needs of that job.
And that's really important.
And that has a lot
of impact, again,
on what you could have
done in the past on-prem,
with a limited
amount of resources,
versus incredibly
elastic infrastructure
inside of a cloud.
All right, so that
was the second one.
The third one is this idea
of exposing on-prem data
to cloud applications.
You want the cloud
applications--
you want the part that
responds to customer requests,
you want the parts that
interact with mobile devices
or back of those services-- you
want those to be as responsive
and scalable as possible.
So very often we see
this where people
want to deploy applications,
their developers
want to be able to work
with new infrastructure,
so they'll use Cloud to
deploy applications into.
But they still need access
to data that's on-prem.
So how do we facilitate that?
So here's the
diagram, and I'll go
through this in-depth
a little bit.
So the first one is, you've
got to get the network
infrastructure spun up.
It's not just about having
good connectivity with all
your applications talking
to each other in a cloud,
or all your stuff that's sitting
on-prem talking to each other.
You've got to facilitate
the connection between them.
That's the first
most important step.
And we do that with two
critical components.
The first is Interconnect.
Cloud Interconnect
let's basically, us,
Google and y'all, find a
common third party partner,
like an Equinix or an L3,
and facilitate low latency IP
connectivity--
IPv4 connectivity.
That's the first,
most important step,
because we want to maximize
the bandwidth between us.
We don't want the network to
be the bottleneck if we're
trying to front on
premise infrastructure,
or on premise data.
So we can get up to
like 10 gig links.
Great, so we've solved
the latency problem
once we do all that.
What's the next important part?
Securing that line, because that
is a public IPv4 connectivity.
We can't just leave
that out in the open,
because then we've got-- anybody
can look at that data passing
through there.
And we want to secure
that as best as possible,
and make sure the only traffic
that we want to go through
that pipe is ours on--
yours and ours alone.
So we do that with VPN.
We have Cloud VPN on our side,
and we have a VPN gateway
on your side.
And we get those two
talking to each other,
and it's a pretty simple step.
We do this via the API, via
the gcloud tool, Deployment
Manager, whatever
the case may be.
It's a very simple
step to just spin up
the VPN gateway on our side
and have it talk to yours.
Once you've done that, we've
got a secure, low latency
link between us.
If you skip this step,
everything else kind of
falls apart.
So this is critical
and it's important.
And it's kind of useful in a
lot of other scenarios as well.
So it's important
to explore this
as you're trying to make this
move into GCP in general.
But after networking, the
next thing we want to do
is front on premise data.
I like using Kubernetes because
it lets me write applications
in one place and
deploy them somewhere
else on any Kubernetes cluster.
So in this example,
I use Kubernetes.
It could really be anything.
But the idea is that
we've secured the link,
we want to give new
applications access to the data.
But we really don't
want to give them,
like, direct, direct
access to the data.
Let them go through a CRED API.
Let those connections
be audited.
Let those queries
and jobs be audited.
Let them get logged very well.
Basically, give
them a modern API
on top of on-prem data
infrastructure that
might be older or might be
newer, it doesn't matter.
But give them a consistent
API to work off of.
Let that front
your data sources.
And it's important to
know to think about
that, because one, certainly
follows a modern development
path if you take this REST
API approach to the world.
But also, as I said earlier,
it gives you an opportunity
to monitor, very closely,
how that data is being used
and where you can
make optimizations.
If you give people direct
access to the database,
you might not have as
much granular control
as you want to have.
Or you might be punting
the access control problem
back to database, maybe to a
system that can't support it.
So it's kind of
cleaner separation
to have this little API,
this thin layer that
sits-- a little shim that
sits between the database
and new applications.
And then the second
thing, or the next thing,
is spinning up the cloud
application infrastructure.
I picked Container Engineer,
but it can really be anything.
It could be App
Engine, it could be
applications running on
Compute Engine, doesn't matter.
But the idea is
that, let us handle
the scale part of the problem.
Use our L7 load balancer
to get one global IP that
works everywhere.
Let that be the thing you give
out to DNS infrastructure.
Send all your traffic
to those applications,
and let us manage the
scale out of aspect.
And then send
traffic back when we
need to get access to that
on-prem infrastructure,
that on-prem data.
The last one-- and this is
sort of the optional step,
it just depends.
If you're inside of
Kubernetes and you're
running Kubernetes
in both places,
you might not really need
the service discovery piece
with something like Console.
Very often, the diagram
is not this simplistic.
It's usually a litany
of applications
on both sides of the
equation that may come and go
and we may shift to the
approach that we're taking.
So it is nice to have a good
cross cluster service discovery
mechanism.
And it's hard to beat Console.
It works pretty well.
It's got a pretty
solid following.
So I'd like to do--
I like to go on this
road pretty often.
All right, so that was
the fronting on-prem data.
The last one I want
to come through
is scaling to meet
IoT workloads.
This goes back to our
connected light bulb scenario.
You've got all
these little devices
that are generating a ton
of data, that are probably
going to a local gateway.
Or if you're familiar with
that Philips Hue system,
they have light bulbs,
and they have the bridge,
and the bridge is what
communicates out from the home.
So in that sort of
a scenario, this
is what it might look like.
You might have the gateway
communicating with a REST API
that's running on App Engine.
Maybe you've got Cloud
Endpoints, maybe you
don't, in front of it.
But you're going to stream
data out from all those bulbs
and you want to
capture all that data.
But you want to
make sure, like we
called at the bottom, that
on premise infrastructure
still has access to that data.
You don't want to lock
it out, because you're
locking out your
ability for everyone
to take advantage of it.
So what does that really--
how do we do that?
Part of the reason you
want to go down this road,
again, it kind of goes back
to the whole on-prem challenge
piece, which is, you've
maxed out resources,
you might not have
any more headroom,
and it takes too
long, even if you
were able to funnel
all that data through,
because of just generic
compute limitations.
So you want to try to find
the best approach here
that again, lets you take
advantage of all the elasticity
and the scalability
on the cloud side,
but doesn't cut off people
from learning from that data
as quickly as possible.
So the first, most critical
component here is Pub/Sub.
How many of you guys have
heard of PubSub already today?
Oh, everybody.
So I could just skip
the slide, right?
I'm going to talk about
this really quickly.
Think of Pub/Sub as a
completely managed--
forget the diagram.
It is a completely managed
message delivery mechanism.
We can create things like
topics and subscriptions.
Subscriptions can be pull or
push based, depending on what
the downstream endpoint is.
And if you think about messages
coming in to infrastructure,
we can actually
split those messages
and have multiple different
mechanisms handle them.
So you might have one mechanism
that's sitting there saying,
I'm going to aggregate
all this data in flight
and I'll write it to a database.
Another one might say,
I'm going to ETL this data
and write it to
a data warehouse.
A third one might say, I'm just
going to pipe these things back
out to another Pub/Sub
topic and send messages
to another application.
You can do all that with
Pub/Sub with, I think,
about three or four
gcloud commands.
Create the topic.
Create a series
of subscriptions.
Each one of them gets their
own copy of the message.
So it's a pretty powerful piece.
And then on top of that, we
have other cool, interesting
features, like labeling.
You can auto expire
certain things by default.
I think by default,
in a subscription,
messages expire in
about seven days.
If you want to tune that, you
can have the ability to tune
that as well.
And in fact, as of I
think a few months ago,
Pub/Sub actually
connects up to Kafka.
So if you've got a Kafka
cluster running on premise,
you can actually hook
up to Kafka ingest,
and as an output source as well.
So you can actually use that
as a mechanism to get data
in and out.
And we do this very
often with customers.
Pub/Sub has a really
easy to use REST API.
That means there
are a ton of tools,
like the Enterprise
Service bus tools
of the world, that
are really critical
to your infrastructure.
Those can actually just
access a REST endpoint as long
as you set them up correctly.
So they're actually
going and hitting
Pub/Sub to get information
back out in a way that's good
and sort of scalable
for them as well.
So the idea here is that we
want to reduce time to insight.
So first, we're going
to have events coming in
off those light bulbs.
They're going to
hit the IoT gateway.
The IoT gateway will
send them to the API.
And the API will start
this chain of events.
So what will first
happen is, those events
get pushed individually to
Pub/Sub as individual messages.
Then we'll have an Apache Beam
pipeline that's running inside
of Dataflow, take in every bit
of those streaming messages.
And because it's in
Dataflow, that Beam pipeline
can grow or scale as
much as it needs to,
and we can shard, reshard, and
reshard that data in flight,
so that we're not dropping
anything on the floor.
And that Dataflow job is
actually going to do a split.
It's going to write things
out into two places.
The first thing
it'll do is, it'll
do maybe a little bit of
light ETL transformation
and kick that stuff
over to BigQuery,
if you want to do kind of SQL on
an ad hoc or exploratory basis
later on, or if
you want to build
a compelling visualization
or a report of that data.
And then what we
might also do is
write the very raw time series
and use Bigtable for that.
The idea of splitting
these things out
is really just by use case.
We might want to do business
analysis in BigQuery.
We might want to use the
Bigtable storage view, the time
series view, as a source for
longer doing machine learning
or experimental use cases.
So it's nice to have the option
of not throwing anything away,
not over normalizing the data.
We have got a lot of options.
Storage is relatively
cheap these days.
Let's write it out
in two places and we
can take advantage of that.
And then the last step is,
the Dataflow job will actually
do a third output and push
things like aggregates.
You might not need to
know every single event
that every single
light generated
from every single home
that they're deployed in.
What you might want to do
is roll up maybe a home,
and say, hey, for this house,
we saw the bulbs change
transition-- or transition from
state to state, maybe n times,
And wrap that up as a single
message, one single piece
of data, like a
single piece of JSON,
and then publish
that to Pub/Sub.
And then you can
have other tools
like the on premise
infrastructure read
from that Pub/Sub topic and
just get the aggregates out.
So now you can start to take
advantage of the idea that,
listen we're going to
offload all the scale
and ingest part of
this problem to Cloud,
but still have access to
the data, pull it back out,
and learn something from it.
And it may go back into other
on premise applications or tools
that are maybe internal facing
or even external facing.
But it gives you the
ability to kind of assess
what's happening in these
houses on a regular basis
without losing any access.
So, we kind of went
through four scenarios.
We burned through
it a little bit
quickly because I do
talk fast, I apologize.
But I'm happy to take questions.
I do want to come to that.
As you think about, how
do we get started here?
There's a lot of detail.
There's a lot of little things.
If you take nothing
else away from today,
don't hesitate to really go
down the path of understanding
network connectivity.
If you don't get that
network part of it right,
everything goes real slow.
And it's really hard to take
advantage of all the scale
when something over here
can run really, really fast,
and you might have enough
infrastructure that runs fast,
but the pipe between
the two is slow,
or you're dropping packets,
or it's not secure.
That's a critical part.
The network is very,
very important,
as you think about it.
And then find a workload
that needs scale.
I'm pretty positive that
every single one of you
could come, stand up
and tell me at least one
workload that
you've run into that
is running out of scale
in the current approach.
You need more
headroom to go faster.
So then you've got
to think about,
how do we actually
make that move?
Do we have to migrate data?
Do we have to
migrate applications?
Do we have to point data
that's coming in to Cloud
and have it go
through that approach?
But you've got to
find something that
makes sense and figure out
what your migration strategy is
going to look like.
And then you want to test
and scale it out, and then
figure out which metrics
or which key PIs are really
important to understand
and say, this
is successful or not successful,
or we have to iterate.
And then the last thing is
really, frankly, be agile.
Be open to shifting the approach
and finding new ways to do it.
But use mechanisms that are
really easy to iterate around.
Things like Pub/Sub
and Cloud storage
are super easy to
work with because you
can put data in a
pretty generic way,
and then you have a
lot of capabilities
to move things around and
reformat what those look like.
A couple of other
sessions I would
suggest that you guys consider
looking into as you're here
today and tomorrow.
So one is open source
data processing on GCP.
That's going to go into
depth on Beam and Hadoop
and Spark running
on Google Cloud.
The next one is migrating data
warehouse to Google BigQuery.
That's a really important one.
That kind of dovetails
right on the first example
we talked about, migrating
on-prem relational
to Cloud Data Warehouse.
And then the last one is
large scale data ingest.
This is true for applications,
mobile devices, IoT,
what have you.
If you have a lot
of data coming in,
how do you do it,
again, in-depth on GCP?